c'est fait brigitte legault la dg du de
la casse est en hausse et passe quand
même sur le wan ho suk pilotes et aux
poires le soir pour se défendre parce
que c'est stressant d'état c'est la
maman d'abréger josé qui est d'origine
italienne qui est tel que ça explique sa
nourriture et tout ce savoureux que la
caq c'est donc une famille qui mangent à
la même table
une famille reconstituée by carrick les
gens qui entourent le go proviennent
tous les horizons politiques
[Musique]
brigitte legault par exemple a été
présidente des jeunes libéraux fédéraux
si le défunt jean lapierre qui lui a
présenté le go moi j'étais au parti
québécois
moi c'est avec le parti conservateur
dans un interview j'ai toujours dit la
politique ce taux de maladies dans ma
théorie l'antidote aux tripes tel
mariage le pacs arrête le quartier
général tout le monde est fébrile après
une semaine difficile le parti a senti
le tapis lui glisser sous les pieds
françois legault vient faire un discours
de ralliement à ses troupes
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'émotion dans l'air il ya la
critique
il y a eu la peur il y a maintenant dans
cet enthousiasme
le soulagement qui avait les moyens
ici on est convaincu d'avoir sauvé les
meubles au débat de tva
martin koskinen 40-50 diriger
l'organisme force jeunesse en 2000 alors
que françois legault était ministre de
l'éducation dans le gouvernement du
parti québécois
il a fondé le parti avec lui c'est son
bras droit son ami son allié de longue
date
c'est beaucoup de pression je dirais là
c'est beaucoup de pression parce que
c'est pas juste son aventure qui ne
concerne avec le temps il faut je suis
un peu plus ému on est une équipe on est
fier de notre équipe mais on veut quand
on veut que ces gens là une chance de
gagner
une autre journée sa mort c'est la
tornade qui s'est abattue hier sur
gatineau change les plans de la journée
le premier ministre y est déjà
et les autres partis ils vont aussi du
gard isabelle donné à gatineau
[Musique]
alors qu'on devait serrer des mers
marché de sainte anne des plaines
on se contentera du mail et de presse à
propos des sinistrés
tajouri ce qu'on allait constater les
dégâts maxime pas de dégâts dans le
visuel c'est un peu spécial
et déjà ils ont posé la question sur le
goût est ce que c'est pas de la
récupération bozizé que les chefs de
parti est aujourd'hui capable
voir des sous-titrés de dire regardez
nous on va leur esprit de solidarité et
on le faire on veut le faire de façon
sobre
en fait j'en ai fait pas mieux perdre
non non non plus au nord donc je dirai
aux joueurs deux heures de route plus
tard qu'en soit le nous et manon massé
sont réunis et ne parle surtout pas du
1er octobre 40 prend rien pour acquis
la caq sait bien que personne à ce stade
ci n'est à l'abri d'une tempête
[Musique]